I think we should give him [ __ ] for not  being here at 12 45. he's here I know  what he's gonna call it doesn't matter  if you're here we stop  we stall around doctor time you know  what I mean doctors aren't on our time  we're on their time  well how are you thank you thank you so  much for doing this I'm  I'm good thank you okay so a good  question is are we good well here's what  I do know in the beginning now it's  going to be us versus each other but at  a certain point I think um if you give  us all equally uh bad information it's  going to be us versus you  um and really we'll be attacking you  personally attacking Western medicine in  general since I'm interpreting this  guess who's going to win  [Music]